I don't use that phrase like it saved my
life
gingerly but I mean that suicide hotline
phone call it saved my life
the this story actually begins prior to
me calling the hotline we used the word
crazy loosely a lot of the time but I
think the best way to describe the
feeling I was having at the time was
crazy I was by myself I was actually on
my way to pick up my daughter at the
time from daycare being on the bus and
feeling crazy like a family like I
wanted to take my clothes off like I
wanted to jump off the bus I wanted to
harm myself I can't call the suicide
hotline on the bus right now because
that's gonna look really crazy so the
best thing to do would be to I had known
that New York has like I forget what the
number is if that were essentially you
can have a text conversation to help you
through the process if you feel like
you're going to harm yourself it was
like look I'm trying to text I text the
message it took like a minute to get
back and it's like what is your problem
it's like okay I'm gonna text you robot
person on the other side what my problem
is okay I don't know what to do I'm
panicking I'm like okay do I run across
the street because at this point I'm
trying to figure out either do I harm
myself would not harm myself like 1 or 2
and I'm like okay well I need I need I
need to do something so I call I called
the suicide hotline and I can't remember
the exact like how the phone call began
essentially but I remember the feeling
of the phone call and I remember being
affirmed because I just felt overwhelmed
and between work between life between
Fatherhood between not really knowing
what I was doing and in that moment it
felt like it was going to be easier to
not be here and to essentially try to
end my life and to have a person kind of
listen to the stress at the moment and
say it is okay you're okay wow this must
be really hard for you this situation
isn't really difficult you're doing a
fantastic job though based on what
you're telling me listening without
judgment without without bias without
prejudice that suicide hotline phone
call saved my life and I wish I could
remember the sister's name was spoke to
because she was so warm she was so
loving she was so comforting she sounded
like a black auntie
warm warmth was the word though no
identifying questions at all she doesn't
know my name she doesn't know where I'm
from she didn't know where I was located
the the the conversation was directly
related to what I was going through at
that present moment and those feelings
she didn't she didn't ask me anything I
was like where are you or you know none
of that part of what she was doing was
disallowing me to space really to vent
it was less questions and more affirming
it was just something I needed because
there's that level of shame you feel
essentially when you're trying to tell a
person that you care about that I
essentially want to harm myself because
then it's very easy unfortunately for
people who do know you to start blaming
themselves I think sometimes this is
their there's a fear right like okay do
I do I make this phone call am i
actually going to look crazy is it crazy
doesn't even work and granted I I'm very
much the person that doesn't believe in
absolute so not everything works for
everybody sometimes maybe it's not the
hotline maybe it's a relative it's a
friend it's someone you know you can
call who's going to essentially be able
to give you that space and that freedom
in that room to give of yourself without
without concern of bias or prejudice or
judgment but the suicide hotline did
that for me for sure it's easy to kind
of stigmatize how a person looks who
might be suffering from some level of
like a mental health disorder a person
who may be depressed I don't look like
the stereotypical person who's been
suffering from that I'm also going
through this in processing this I know
you probably are too I've kind of been
blessed and fortunate enough to be given
the opportunity to have the language and
have the space to do that so it feel
like it's kind of my duty to kind of
share that with other people
[Music]
you